i think that
the entire way that we reacted to kovid
kind of exposes all of this i think it
does so in bright and dramatic colors
which is it really is kind of the first
modern civilization that has willingly
sacrificed the young to placate the old
and there is no other way to describe it
i mean some people will reject the
premise but we went from shutting down
schools because it might hurt kids to
shutting down schools because they might
transmit a virus to grandma that's a
totally different moral argument by the
way totally different for the first
moral argument is like okay it might
kill young people i get that the next is
oh now they might get infected and they
might kill grandma i'm not into that
obviously i want to protect seniors but
that's a totally different argument
which is like okay we must inhibit your
development we must suppress your life
experience and your activities because
you might then hurt the generation that
does not have as many years left to live
and so yes i think an intergenerational
apology is necessary totally and i will
say that kind of that 35 to 54 year old
bracket is the i think it is going to be
in my opinion the great swing to the
right that no one expected
but you said something interesting there
about the intergenerational version of
this and i've been thinking about this a
lot that so many of the people that are
in power right now or at least appear to
be in power say joe biden say nancy
pelosi
say you know any of these people really
any of them you can dianne feinstein who
everyone knows is almost incapacitated
at this point just the amount of of uh
you know they're not i guess they're
upper end boomers but they're also the
last of the great generations something
like that but these people that are in
their say mid 70s and up that are still
clinging to power nancy pelosi with that
ridiculous re-election video from two
weeks ago and it's like lady you're 81
go be a grandma like enough do you think
there's something what do you think that
is psychologically maybe about that
generation that they can't let go
because that does seem to be a big
problem here and i've seen in just the
last couple of weeks that suddenly gen x
i'm 45 right in the middle of gen x like
my generation you're you're a little
younger than me so you're not you're gen
y is that fair to say
i'm uh i'm millennial yeah
you're millennial no offense uh but that
that
the 35 right but the 35 36 to say 54
year olds we just haven't had our chance
yet because for some reason those people
kept hanging on at every level do you
think there's something psychologically
going on there that that didn't allow
them to let go
yeah you're going to get me in a lot of
trouble dave because we talk about this
a lot and the angriest emails i get are
on this topic so uh buckle up i suppose
you said something super interesting
which
nancy pelosi go be a grandma
and she kind of still sees herself as
this like 33 year old kind of like aids
crusader in west san francisco that his
eyebrows keep getting higher
yeah but do you know what i mean which
is like okay like you've had your chance
go look beyond yourself that's what a
grandma's all about right yeah like go
look about go look towards the next
generation and are you actually
preserving things that are beautiful
true and good for her it's kind of like
no i still have to have that one more
election cycle you don't understand
because that's when the real revolution
is going to happen
and so look i mean it's the tyranny of
the septuagenarians and the
octogenarians and there's a lot of great
people in the 70s and 80s category in
our country it just so happens none of
them are in leadership right now
right so it just so happens that the
cream that
whatever's risen to the top isn't the
best and so you kind of have a through
line of biden and schumer and pelosi
that have been in this schtick for 30 or
40 years literally
and they don't really care about the
damage they're leaving to the next
generation it's kind of like they want
to have their two to four years to rule
over the ashes and they're gonna die
and i hate to be so morbid about it but
they're on the back nine of the back
nine they're on like hole 17 right and
so you got to start all of a sudden look
like who's the next group of people that
are going to be playing now you know
you've had eric weinstein on your
program before he talks about the ego
the embedded growth obligation i think
that's a really smart perspective about
how this is a generation that has
literally experienced nothing but
prosperity economically their entire
life and has gotten used to it and acts
as if that is something that is just
kind of baked in the human existence
things get better don't get in my way
but i think that
the entire way that we reacted to covid
kind of exposes all of this i think it
does so in bright and dramatic colors
which is it really is kind of the first
modern civilization that has willingly
sacrificed the young to placate the old
and there is no other way to describe it
i mean some people will reject the
premise but we went from shutting down
schools because it might hurt kids to
shutting down schools because they might
transmit a virus to grammar that's a
totally different moral argument by the
way totally different for the first
moral argument is like okay it might
kill young people i get that the next is
oh now they might get infected and they
might kill grandma i'm not into that
obviously i want to protect seniors but
that's a totally different argument
which is like okay we must inhibit your
development we must suppress your life
experience and your activities because
you might then hurt the generation that
does not have as many years left to live
and so yes i think an intergenerational
apology is necessary totally and i will
say that kind of that 35 to 54 year old
bracket is the i think it is going to be
in my opinion the great swing to the
right that no one expected i think
there's more red pilling happening
between ages 35 to 54. and there's a lot
of boomers that are really conservative
and god bless them for that and they
continue to be but there is kind of this
question of like the 42 year old mom
that looks she's like wait a second you
know i wasn't able to get the career
advancement that maybe that i wanted
because i had to wait for boomers to age
out and now my kids have to wear masks
because a bunch of septuagenarians are
worried about this and i think that
we're experiencing
the kind of the climax of generational
tension and we saw this i'll say one
final thing in this dave which is
this is nothing new this kind of immoral
behavior
first manifested itself through fiscal
policy a generation that was willing to
borrow hundreds of billions of dollars
to add to the national debt in 2009 2010
2011 2012 with no regard for the fiscal
health of future generations is the same
type of generation that locks down
seventh graders and doesn't think
anything of it so you know that we just
do that around here okay like we'll put
their life on hold we'll steal their
savings we'll steal their purchasing
power because i'm important and i matter
and i think that really i think that
betrays the social contract i think
it goes directly against what it means
to be a patriotic citizen
you say 35 to 54 are going to be the red
child red pill generation it's like i'm
45. i know a little something about this
red pill situation right so it's like
i'm i'm with you man i i feel it um you
know you see those those pictures online
of you know stacy abrams unmasked in
front of the kids and hoco over in new
york smiling with the kids it's like
these kids are going to do some pretty
horrible things to old people one day
you can really feel it do you not not
just to talk about it at an idea level
but because you're around so many
college kids kids i mean they're young
adults
through turning point have you seen a
real shift in their attitudes on this
stuff you know we go to the events when
i go to turn point events it's always so
positive and fun and all that stuff but
like have you seen
a difference in the way they're reacting
with the ideas or resentment or whatever
it might be
definitely on the center right for sure
our students are pushing back like crazy
all right we have
we have a list i was just going through
we have 35 schools that have staged
walkouts in the last 24 hours at turning
point usa over the mass mandates and we
support them 100 we're helping them with
pr support and and times legal support
all that stuff because the mass mandates
have gone out of control but i will say
dave that the mass
propaganda dare i say mass formation
psycho psychosis trying to get us both
taken out man
yeah there we go well i figured this
will be on local so we know the owner
they want to go by spotify so
yeah exactly but you know that kind of
mass propaganda campaign has really
worked on a lot of young people and
it's kind of a great irony where and
this is a stereotype but the average
70 year old 60 or 70 year old right now
is far less concerned about covid than i
think the average 17 year old
and that's a stereotype that's like a
generalization i should say but there
has been a lot of induced fear
amongst high school and college kids
completely and totally unnecessarily and
there's a cost to pay for that it's
going to be a generation that is the
least free thinking generation absent
our intervention and trying to get them
their humanity back it's the most
medicated generation most suicidal
generation the most confused generation
the
most directionalist generation but we're
starting to see some pushback against
this and some hopefully writing of that
trajectory
but i don't think it's enough i don't
think that this is going to fix itself i
think that we need and i don't say this
lightly you know that i'm a small
government conservative guy but i think
that we need a collective intervention
to try to fix some of these trends that
have gone so awry i don't just think
that we're like oh well we shut
everything down for two years we
vaccinated kids didn't need it and put
masks on them they had no social
development they are not speaking the
way they should the iqs are stunted like
everything's going to kind of sort
itself out i'm not as convinced of that
i'm not i think there's some very
interesting bold robust entrepreneurial
and creative ideas that could probably
fix this but i'll be honest dave
there's been a little glimmer of hope
amongst some of the young people but
it's nowhere near the type of rebellion
that i would like to see it isn't i saw
far more activism and energy around
greta thundberg's the world is ending
climate change propaganda and far more
energy amongst the average high school
kid around floyda palooza than i did
around masked mandates vaccine mandates
or being locked down and not being able
to see their friends if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell